An addictive new season of You has arrived
on Netflix as serial stalker Joe heads to
LA in search of a fresh start and perhaps
a true Love story.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!
I'm Jan and in this video I'm discussing the
ending of Season 2 of You, revealing all the
clues that predicted the big twist in the
finale, and explaining what that final shot
really means for Season 3.
We will be talking spoilers, of course, so
take care if you're not all caught up.
The final episode of Season 2, appropriately
titled "Love, Actually", explains the twist
that Love is as dark and warped as Joe and
also a serial killer like him.
"We're soulmates Joe."
At this point, Love has just murdered Candace
in cold-blood, something foreshadowed right
from the very first episode when Joe arrives
in LA and sees the body of a red-head girl
lying in a pool of blood.
That was just an actress filming a scene,
but the placement of the heart-shaped sunglasses
and the black leather jacket were the first
sign that Candace wouldn't make it out of
LA alive.
And as Love reveals how and why she did what
she did, the parallels between her and Joe
become even more striking.
Love killed Delilah and Candace, because they
were both obstacles in the way of her forming
a family with Joe, similar to how Joe killed
Benji and Peach in Season 1 when he saw them
as being in the way of his relationship with
Beck.
Right from the moment they met, Love latched
on to Joe as a means to fulfil her fantasy
of having a happy family:
"I knew right away, in my gut, I recognized
something in you.
A little darkness that made you less storybook,
more real.
I started to fantasize again."
In in the first episode, it's Love who makes
a move on Joe, scuppering his plan to accidentally
bump into her.
And like Joe, Love is able to charm those
around her, something he immediately picks
up on.
"You have a way with people, they just like
you."
Again the same as Joe, Love is perceptive
and she immediately recognises the darkness
in him and compares it to herself.
"Yeah, I thought about getting you something
happy.
But let's face it, what you're more interested
in is something smart and complex.
A little dark.
That's what makes you feel at home.
How do you know that?
Well cause me too."
After Candace reveals the truth about Joe's
real identity to the Quinns, Love begins to
investigate him more thoroughly, but his dark
past doesn't deter her one bit.
She steals the keys to his creepy lock-up
where she finds his cage and figures out the
truth about Beck and Joe's relationship.
"I devoured your dead ex's book All the articles,
all the think pieces, reading between the
lines.
And I realized, Guinevere Beck was unspecial
and mediocre.
She didn't deserve you."
And it's very similar to how Joe felt about
Beck's original boyfriend Benji.
"I do understand something about you now,
Beck.
You somehow think this guy is all you deserve."
Love even seems to admire Joe's brutal actions
seeing them as a mirror of her own violent
past.
"Yeah, you did some terrible things but that's
what sensitive people do when they're trapped
in a bad relationship."
By the way, Love's affinity for knives and
murder was signalled early on in the season
when we see her butchering a rack of ribs
in a scene that's intercut with shots of Joe
chopping up Jasper's dead body.
And Love's preference for slashing her victims
in the throat was also hinted at when she
fake attacks Joe in the neck with a toy wolf
during her family's wellness weekend.
So, Love may be what Joe originally considered
his soulmate, but he actually seems disappointed
in the love he found in her by the end of
the season, and he ponders this at Lucy and
Sunrise's wedding.
"All I've ever wanted is to love and be loved
by someone real and true.
[Joe] Me too.
Is that what we are?
Soulmates?
Is this what real love is?
Knowing and accepting anything."
I think his state of unease stems from his
twisted beliefs about romantic love, mixed
with his confused feelings over whether he's
really a good or bad person.
On the one hand, Joe still harbours delusions
of himself as a nice guy and saviour.
"The hero races to the cage,
he raises the door, and steps inside,
eager to set Delilah free,
and begin the rest of his life."
And in the first episode, he even claims he's
a changed man.
"I don't fantasize to some impossible version
of a woman I barely know."
However, we quickly see he's repeating similar
patterns to what he did with Beck, and by
the time of the finale, Love herself accuses
Joe of glossing over the truth with his own
warped version of reality.
"Because while I was seeing you, really seeing
you, you were busy gazing at a goddamn fantasy.
A perfectly imperfect girl.
You saw what you wanted to see."
In Season 2, Joe keeps making the point that
he's trying to change, especially after a
vision of Beck confronts him over her murder
in the second episode.
Unlike Benji who he caged then killed in season
1, he lets his first captive Will go free,
and the two murders he does commit don't seem
to be premeditated.
The first is in self-defence when Jasper attacks
him, and Henderson was pushed down the stairs
as he tried to escape.
As Joe's original plan was to have Henderson
confess his crimes on camera.
But we have to remember that much of what
we see in You is presented through Joe's point-of-view
and that he is an unreliable narrator who
spends a good deal of time rationalising his
own often creepy and violent behaviour.
Joe may have saved Ellie from Henderson, but
after he traps the sleazy celebrity, he's
forced to consider how much difference there
really is between Henderson and himself.
Joe believes his actions are noble, but Henderson
quickly dismantles that illusion.
"You feel like you're a piece of shit so you're
trying to be a hero.
Ruining my life is not gonna save you from
your demons, all right?"
We're the same.
[Joe] No, no...
I'm nothing... like you."
We know of course that Joe has manipulated,
drugged, knocked out, and trapped people to
fulfil his own desires and he's even killed
them.
Henderson has done similar, minus the killing,
except he's targeted underage girls.
So who is worse?
It's a difficult and unsettling question,
that Joe is definitely not willing to address.
"We're nothing alike.
He's trying to win with words and ideas that
add up to nothing.
He is bad.
Someone needs to stop him and he knows it."
In a way, Henderson and Love are two sides
of the same coin for Joe as they both force
him to look at himself and reflect on his
own actions and he feels threatened and absolutely
terrified by that.
"No, this isn't me.
This isn't me anymore.
I didn't want to do that.
I didn't do that."
As co-creator Sera Gamble has said, part of
what they're exploring in the show is "the
ultimate question of how self-aware Joe can
get" and even the showrunners say they "don't
really know the ultimate answer to that yet."
Joe's inability to properly confront and deal
with his past crimes continues through the
season.
In the sixth episode, he plans to go to Candace's
Airbnb to abduct her and presumably kill her
once and for all.
And in the eighth episode, when Forty pretends
to be Beck to re-enact her murder, Joe begins
to hear Beck's voice accusing him and he can't
handle it.
"[Beck] You're not special.
You're broken.
I could never love you.
You are the bad thing.
You are the thing that you should have killed."
So he begins to strangle Forty for real just
as he did with Beck.
Then later, when Forty asks Joe
"How do you think Dr Nicky hid his sociopathy
for so long?"
Joe justifies the actions of Beck's killer
- that's himself of course - with yet more
self-delusions.
"Why does he have to be a sociopath?
Maybe he's a man who would do anything for
love."
Later on, a vision of Joe's mother tells him:
"People like us don't change.
I've changed.
So why are you already thinking of ways to
get rid of Forty."
Like Lady Macbeth, Joe sees his own culpability
and complicity in the deaths of those around
him, in a vision of his own bloodied hands.
And then when Joe discovers that Forty has
actually cracked a code hidden in Beck's autobiography
that it was her ex-boyfriend who killed her
and not Dr Nicky, he grabs a piece of glass
and goes to kill Forty.
He doesn't follow through, but that's only
because he hears about Forty's childhood trauma
with the family's murdered au pair.
And after Joe thinks that he's killed Delilah
himself, he begins to believe that he deserves
to be punished:
"I'm done with excuses.
I'm done blaming everyone else for the things
I've done.
But it's time I take responsibility.
Accept the punishment for my crime.
That a cage is where I belong."
This idea fits in with the literary reference
to Dostoevsky's novel "Crime and Punishment"
which appeared in both the first and last
episodes of Season 2.
"In Crime and Punishment, the hero willingly
walks into exile.
He is killed, but he's also found love.
And if he repents, he can be redeemed.
He and the woman he loves can be saved."
Dr Nicky echoes a similar idea about deserving
punishment when Forty goes to see him in prison
with evidence that could prove the therapist
didn't kill Beck.
Dr Nicky refuses to co-operate even though
he knows that he's innocent of that crime,
because he believes he should be punished
nonetheless for his other sins.
"I didn't kill Beck, but I am guilty.
I'm guilty of using her.
And she's not the first.
No, I'm a bad person.
I'm exactly where I deserve to be."
However, Joe seems willing to switch how he
feels about whether he deserves to punished.
Although he says he's now trapped in a cage,
forced to live with a woman he no longer loves,
which you could see as a sort of fitting punishment,
in the very final scene we see him quickly
revert to his old tricks.
"I had no idea that the cage I was building
all this time was a trap for me.
But that's not how destiny works, is it?
This is just the beginning...
because this is where I had to be, exactly...
where I had to be to meet... you."
As we can see, Joe has started on a new delusional
path, twisting reality, and pretending to
himself that falling for Candace, Beck and
Love were just errors in a greater scheme,
blips along the path of destiny to meet a
literate and literal girl next door.
Now this scene is clearly teasing a setup
for Season 3, and just before I get to that
and explain why we're very likely to get at
least two more seasons before Joe perhaps
gets the justice he deserves,
I want to let you know that thanks to this
video's sponsor NordVPN, all our viewers can
get a very special holiday deal of 81% off
Nord's fantastic virtual private network;
as well as four bonus months for free, plus
free access to the Nord Password Manager.
Just visit NordVPN.com/Flicks or tap the link
in the video description.
So, to understand what will happen next season,
we need to remember that by the very end Joe
isn't in love with Love anymore.
After she revealed her true nature to Joe,
his romantic illusion was shattered, and when
Love refused to let Joe out of the cage, he
said to himself that he would do what Beck
did to him and "pretend" to love her.
"What did Beck do in this situation?
[Beck] I love you.
[Joe] Right.
She pretended to love me.
You're asking me to see you, to love you.
I don't know what to feel, Love.
But I know what to do."
In fact, Joe almost kills Love, until she
reveals that she's pregnant and carrying his
baby.
This is the only thing that stopped him from
murdering her, as protecting children is something
that Joe responds to in particular.
He went out of his way in both seasons, even
putting himself in danger, to protect both
Paco and Ellie.
And he even tried to help Delilah perhaps
because of what Henderson did to her as a
child.
This all probably relates back to how Joe
feels about his own troubled childhood and
so he sympathises with children and wants
to help them.
At the end of the season, this is how Joe
sees himself:
"I'm ready to be the good father I never had.
To make the family I always dreamed of.
The one she deserves."
However, whether Joe really sticks around
is immediately undermined at the very end
as we see him beginning to stalk the woman
next door.
We know he believes he's trapped himself in
a cage with Love, so it's quite likely he
will try and escape, perhaps with his daughter
even, and run to somewhere far from LA.
For anyone who isn't already aware, this TV
show is based on the books "You" and "Hidden
Bodies" by author Caroline Kepnes and she
already has two new books planned in the series.
According to EW, "the third book will see
Joe move to the Pacific Northwest with a plan
to become a family man in his own unique way."
Now, the TV show has deviated from the books
in various significant ways, but if Joe needs
to leave LA in a hurry, say because Love catches
him creeping on their neighbour, and tries
to kill him, then fleeing to another state
feels like something he would do, given that's
what he did when Candace returned to confront
him in New York.
He might also run off with his daughter to
get her away from the clutches of the powerful
and corrupt Quinn family.
And remember that he's still in contact with
Will in Manila who could help him get set
up with new identities in a new location.
And given the popularity of the show, I can't
see the showrunners wanting to end Joe's story
in the third season either, especially as
there is at least a fourth book planned in
the series.
Which means, that I expect it's unlikely Joe
will see justice for any of his crimes until
season 4, at which point perhaps Candace's
prediction will eventually come true.
"Murder has a way of following you,
and you're not getting away with it."
On the subject of being stalked online, if
you want to secure yourself from hackers,
malicious websites and even your own internet
service provider selling your online browsing
history to advertisers, then a VPN is essential.
A VPN creates a secure, encrypted tunnel between
your device and a VPN server, stopping your
ISP or any other agencies from tracking you
online, reading your emails, private messages
or what websites you're visiting.
Unlike free VPNs, Nord is super-fast with
more than 5,000 servers in over 60 countries;
and when I put it to the test, I was still
able to get blisteringly fast download speeds
over my home connection.
NordVPN is also great in helping you bypass
any blocks on videos or websites which aren't
viewable in your country.
With NordVPN, you can quickly pick a server
in any country and then browse the internet
as if you were there.
Nord's VPN even unlocks Netflix shows that
may not be available in your home country.
The interface is amazingly intuitive and you
can connect up to six devices at the same
time so you can keep your mobile devices and
laptops safe whenever you're travelling or
using insecure public wifi in a coffee shop,
for example.
On top of that, NordVPN offers a unique feature
called CyberSec which provides ad blocking
and protection against malware, and Nord has
a no-log policy meaning it doesn't record
any of your browsing.
With our special holiday deal, NordVPN are
offering all our viewers up to 81% off new
subscriptions, an additional four months for
free and access to the Nord Password Manager
at no additional cost.
Just visit NordVPN.com/Flicks or tap the link
in the video description to access the offer.
For just the price of a monthly cup of coffee
you can secure your internet browsing from
spies and hackers.
That's NNordVPN.com/Flicks for a huge 81%
discount and four months entirely free.
So, how do you feel about the ending for Joe
and Love in Season 2?
And what would you like to see happen in Season
3?
Comment with your thoughts below.
And if you enjoyed this, I'll be reviewing
new seasons of Chilling Adventures of Sabrina,
Lucifer and Stranger Things as they come out
so make sure you subscribe to get all my new
videos.
Tap left for my next video or tap right for
another video you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!